la justicia para a brión a taylor este
fue el lema de la cabecera de la marcha
conmemorativa por el aniversario de la
muerte de la joven afroamericana la
policía la mató por error cuando
irrumpió en su casa y este sábado
cientos de personas salieron en
wikileaks quien está aquí para
homenajearla ahora todo el mundo está
diciendo su nombre vio la tele
la multitud finalizó la marcha en
jefferson square park donde durante
meses se produjeron manifestaciones para
protestar por la muerte de la joven de
26 años en el lugar activistas han hecho
murales carteles obras de arte y otros
recuerdos en honor a su vida me dicen
que estoy creando una hermosa niña afro
y quiero que llegue a saber que nadie
puede matarla y salirse con la suya
uruguay verter también hubo marchas en
otras partes del país como nueva york el
suceso conmocionó a la comunidad
afroamericana estadounidense y continúa
latente que este sábado importa mil
personajes públicos rindieron homenaje a
taylor como la estrella de basket lebron
james
y su nombre continúa descansando en el
paraíso reina brión a hace un año
agentes encubiertos ingresaron por la
fuerza y sin anunciarse en el domicilio
de taylor por lo que su pareja disparó
al confundirlos con criminales éstos
respondieron con 32 disparos acabando
con la vida de peón a taylor
la familia y líderes de la comunidad
negra acusan a la policía y al fiscal
general del estado de encubrir lo
ocurrido aunque la ciudad de louisville
pagó 12 millones de dólares a la familia
y se comprometió a reformar la policía